The fire nation is embracing the dark path
and the world might never recover.
The world needs the avatar.
It needs you and
if our nation is destroyed, everything in their paths,
right.
They're going to say, We're the world.
if the world is going to have any chance,
it's going to need a
I chased down every hint of the avatar.
It's just my destiny.
You got to do this one.
If me, Tara and a flying ball at four
I'm not someone who can stop the fire nation.
I don't want the responsibility.
The world needs you
to remember what it is we're really fighting for.
The ones we
love.
I'm the avatar, and I'm going to save the world
with my friends.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
Netflix dropped a brand new Avatar
The Last Airbender Trailer
There's a whole bunch of new footage
and Easter eggs here, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for the episode,
so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
and Remember.
In addition to this,
Mike and Brian are also making animated Avatar
The Last Airbender movies, and a brand new series
that we'll see in the next couple of years, too.
so Avatar fans are going to be eating good
for the next couple of years.
there's a lot of very familiar Avatar
The Last Airbender theme music that they played
during this trailer or Netflix versions of the Avatar
The Last Airbender theme music.
but they actually start the trailer with Monk Gyatso
voiceover talking to Ang in the past
before he goes into the eyes
about how the world needs the avatar
This is meant to be when the fire nation is attacking,
but during the series
they're actually going to show us
the genocide of the air nomads way back before
he went into the ice during the original Avatar
the last Airbender episodes.
They just talked about that in past tense.
And you saw a couple of flashbacks
but it looks like what they've done is
they cut his voiceover in the past
with this in the present day.
This actually looks like it's happening
during the finale and they're coming for the Northern
Water tribe because they're a bunch of different Fire
Nation ships instead of just Zuko's ship.
Because when he came to the Southern Water Tribe
defining for the first time,
it was just his ship with Iroh.
So it kind of looks like they actually have a little
bit of footage in here from the very end of the series,
although most of the footage is from much earlier
in the series.
this actually looks like them a little bit later
during the winter solstice
when they're reaching the scores for
this is where they meet the spirit panda.
Hey, by an ng winds that meeting the spirit of Roku
who tells them about going to the Crescent Island
in the mission that he needs.
Like the special lesson that he needs
at the Crescent Island the scorch here is from the fire
nations attack long ago that caused
hey by to attack a bunch of innocent villagers.
He winds up capturing Sagar.
So it's a little bit of an adventure here.
I don't know how much they're doing here from
the original episodes, when Monk Gyatso also says the world
might never recover, that's a reference to this episode
with Hey By where Aang actually showed him an acorn
and that the force would eventually regrow
like things will eventually get better
this is meant to be the beginning of episode
one with them actually
showing the genocide of the air nomads
this might actually be fire Lord.
So as in attacking then they show Aang coming
out of the ice in the first episode
we get a little bit of classic theme music from Avatar
The Last Airbender,
this does not look like a flashback.
This looks like from present day in the fire
nation caught with fire, Lord Ozai and his men
This is meant to be one of the big changes
from the original season one.
So we didn't really see a Zulu that much
until like the very end of season one
and then mostly during season two
when she becomes one of the big antagonists.
what they said they've changed for the live action
series is
they made her a bigger character in season one,
just to flesh out her character arc a little bit more
so that she doesn't show up for like 5 seconds
in a post-credits scene in the last episode.
And then we don't really see her until like season two.
so way, way more of Azula in season one, this time,
not totally clear where this attack from the fire
nation is coming.
It could be on Kyoshi Island.
this is just a team up attack from Zuko in Iroh.
It seems like after they bailed on the Fire Nation
because one of the big turns during
the season is that Zuko in Cairo becomes
sort of like backup antagonist
and and really winds up being Commander
Zhao That winds up being the actual main antagonist.
They should look very familiar. It happened
the first couple of episodes of the original series
is the Ruins of the Southern Air Temple.
This is where Ayn goes into the Avatar state again
because it gets so pissed off.
Remembering what actually happened to the air
Nomads is basically him witnessing the aftermath
of what he missed when he took off into the ocean
and went down into the ice
Like this is all the destruction that happened.
All your friends died,
all the people that you cared about because you ran
off, theoretically, in his mind,
like he blames himself for all this happening.
this is probably in the southern water tribe
before Zuko comes to attack looking for him
this just seems like Katara talking to Sokka,
trying to explain to him why he needed to help
Aang on his mission to make it to the Crescent Islands
this actually looks like
Kyoshi Island though, because you see the statue
of Kyoshi in the background there.
we're actually supposed to get some sort of flashback
to Kyoshi during season one.
we get a little bit more of Appa.
We even see Momo later in the trailer to so far, the
special effects on them actually look pretty decent.
little bit more of him trying to impress everyone.
A kyoshi village
little bit more comedy from Saga For a second,
I almost thought that he was actually eating a cabbage,
but we actually don't see cabbage man
till he actually makes it to the Earth Kingdom.
and do not worry, Cabbage Man does appear during
the season.
there was actually a brief scene
in the last trailer of them entering Omashu.
They actually see him for the first time
when they enter the city here this ship by itself
just seems like it belongs to Zuko and Iroh probably
during the first couple of episodes when they're down
near the Southern Water tribe and they wind up
seeing Aang's signal as he comes out of the ice.
we get a little footage of him talking to Iroh
about his whole mission is basically like episode one
where he's explaining who he is, what he's doing,
why he cares about his honor so much,
all of the means that you remember from Zuko,
I must captured the avatar and reclaim my honor.
notice on his wall here in the ship, you see pictures
of a bunch of airbenders in the background.
These are previous airbenders.
These are a bunch of air nomads.
He's just trying to familiarize himself with what
Aang might look like because they don't actually know
all the designs of his men
look like they're right out of the series,
lot of people are going to be commenting on Zuko's
scar.
It's not quite as big as it is on the animated series.
Like they toned the scar down just a little bit.
a lot of people will remember Paul Sung Lee
from The Mandalorian.
More recently. He was also on Kim's convenience.
but one of the funny coincidences
on that show, people called him Oppa.
So we have Oppa on a show with Oppa.
He also kind of looks like he was born to play Iroh.
not expecting any leaves from the vine or any, like,
super cry worthy moments from him during season one.
Maybe he's a couple of cry worthy moments,
but like, the real cry worthy stuff
doesn't really happen to like season two
when they make it to the Earth Kingdom
we get a little bit of voiceover dialog
from Aang talking about stopping the fire nation.
Not sure if he can actually do it.
they we see more of Ozai at the Fire Nation Palace.
and it looks like this
scene is actually going to be a flashback or
they're actually going to show us him
giving Zuko his scar.
this is also one of those moments
during the original Avatar The Last Airbender series
that we only saw in flashback
when characters were remembering
like Iroh was remembering these events happening.
Like I said, one of the things they said
they changed for the live action series is they show us
some of these scenes in a much bigger way.
this is actually art Arden Cho playing June.
She's riding on her Nyla's from the original series.
She's meant to be a bounty hunter
in the original series coming from the Earth Kingdom,
basically working for the fire nation,
trying to capture the Avatar as well.
This is meant to be Kyoshi Island.
Still with the fire nation coming for the village.
Suki in the background with the Kyoshi warriors
like I said, Commander
Zhao meant to be the main antagonist of season one.
we get a much bigger battle between the Kyoshi Warriors
and the Fire Nation soldiers.
then we finally see Omashu, who also happens
pretty early
during the original series,
there was the a bunch of Aang and Zuko teaming up.
When he becomes the blue spirit
for the first time in the series.
this actually after Commander Zhao has captured him
and Zuko basically has to free him
because he doesn't want Commander
Zhao to be the one to return him to fire Ozaki
because he can't reclaim his honor
if he's not the one to actually return him.
so he's actually trying to save him, not to help him,
but so that he can actually claim his honor back.
but it's just meant to be one of the early moments
in the series where they actually do team up
like Zuko doesn't really become part of Team Avatar
until much later in the series.
this seems like it's from much earlier in the series
when Zuko comes with a southern water
tribe looking for him them inside the Earth kingdom
fighting the fire nation.
Then we actually get our first footage of King
Bumi during the Omashu episode.
the much older version of King Bumi
giving him a little taste of earth bending.
Because at this point
Aang hasn't learned how to Earth bend yet.
Toph is the person who actually teaches him
how to earth. Bend.
But the whole idea is he doesn't really learn to earth
bend until season two or book two.
However you want to think about it.
this looks like Katara water
bending inside the northern water
tribe towards the end of the series
because she also doesn't really learn to water
bend in a much more complete way
until she gets lessons at the very end of season one.
just because of his topknot here,
it actually looks like she's fighting Zuko here.
this actually seems like get a lot of people wondering
if they do get on the series.
this is more of them.
In the very beginning of the series
with Zuko attacking Aang at the Southern Water tribe,
lot of footage from those first couple of episodes
then we get and going into the Avatar state again
and just a reminder
that all the episodes are dropping February
22nd binge style
because we are talking about Netflix here.
they haven't said
when book two or season two is going to release.
I think part of the idea is
they want to get everything out as quickly as possible.
Hopefully, hopefully they have a plan to get season
two out by at least next year.
But it could be two years because of the strike delays
that would actually mean that season two releases
the same year that Mike and Bryan's brand new avatar
The Last Airbender animated movie
is also supposed to release.
That's supposed to be with an older version of team Aang.
lot of people wanted them to actually just adapt
some of the comics for some of the animated Avatar
The Last Airbender stuff like Just do forward in the
timeline for Team Aang after the events of Book three.
seems like you all got your wish.
That's going to be the first animated movie.
They'll be multiple animated movies, though.
That's an avatar Studios is all about
like they started their own studio.
They're going to be making brand new Avatar
animated series and movies, the brand new
animated Avatar The Last Airbender series
is actually going to be about the next Earth
bender Avatar after Korra, though that won't premiere,
I think, until 2026.
So it's a little further off.
but there's a whole bunch of brand new footage here.
This trailer looks way better than the last one
if there's any Easter eggs.
You spotted that I didn't talk about
or any big questions you have about the series,
just write them in the comments below
and I'll just continue doing more videos
as we get more footage for the series
we just got a brand new Invincible Season 2 Part
2 trailer
Click here for that and click here
for all my other avatar The Last Airbender
Trailers
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!